how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival at how do
I get in
so the title of this debate is the
limits of thought and I think that it
comes out of the question of what the
relationship is between language and
thought so it used to be thought in the
17th century in the 18th century that
the mind was a kind of theater of ideas
the theater of perceptions and
experiences and language was something
that was kind of added on after that
that you have thoughts or perceptions
and then you had words that named those
perceptions and then in the 20th century
as I'm sure you all know there's what
sometimes terms the linguistic term
according to which it wasn't thought
that Lang perception was prior to
language but rather that language might
in some sense constitute thought and
today to explore that question that
debate we have a head-to-head between on
the one hand Stanley fish Stanley fish
is well I just don't know really where
to start in explaining his extraordinary
career Stanley fish is at the moment a
professor of law at Cardozo law school
he has been an extremely is an extremely
eminent literary critic
I remember reading his amazing book
surprised by sin about Milton and he has
also turned his house to methodological
questions and of particular relevance to
us today is his book winning arguments
on the outside within with John in the
person of John McWhorter we have a man
who is the associate professor of
English and comparative literature at
Columbia University and a specialist in
language and in race relations of his
many books one of his books on race is
the brilliant winning the race and a
particular interest to us today is his
book the language hoax which is
subtitled why the world looks the same
in any language so you're already
getting a sense of their distinct
positions and I'm going to ask them to
begin by setting up
Stoll's for five minutes each and I'm
going to ask them each to address the
question can we think outside of
language Stanley that question you
referred to and that's the 17th century
and the work of Francis Bacon which we
briefly discussed and especially his
fear of what he called the idols of the
tribe the idols of the theater and the
idols of language because like others in
the 17th century many members of the
Royal Society British Royal Society
there was a general fear of language and
language was regarded as something that
stood in the way of accurate perception
and they can go so far as to say that
language and language use especially the
kind of language used that leads us
astray is one of the primary
consequences and Heritage's of the fall
of Adam and Eve as is of course the
later second fall the Tower of Babel and
so bacon famously proposes his method
his method which is a method generally
of severe falsification requirements so
that propositions will not be assented
to until a very rigorous set of tests
has been administered and he thought if
we did that consistently would we would
be able to eliminate the dangers of
language and he actually said this and
in six generations we will have a
complete and accurate description of the
entire world that was in about 1607 so
that's the situation we're in now what
what bacon was participating in it was a
very old project which began with
attempts in the Middle Ages and early
modern period and perhaps he
earlier than that to recover the
language of Edith and it was assumed
that the language of evening was
characterized by the instant and correct
relationship between words and things
that was the possession of Adam when he
spoke so that when Adam named the
animals at least in Milton's Paradise
Lost he did so with words that
penetrated to their essence a notion
that Plato satirized
in one of in one of his dialogues now
the idea behind all of this is that if
we get rid of this distorting medium
language we will come closer in contact
with the genuine and unmediated facts of
the world and there have been many many
efforts to do this in many suggestions
of the steps that we might take again in
the 17th century a member of the Royal
Society named John Wilkins proposed a
linguistic theory in which he said we
can do three things get rid of equivocal
z' that is words that have more than one
meaning get rid of redundancies that is
things that refer to by more than one
word and then get rid of metaphors he
said which are of course which tell us
what something is like and not what it
is and so if we do all of this we were
won against we once again succeed in
purging ourselves of all of the errors
made to language in the history of use
of this effort in the West and in
England typically the most popular
version of this fantasy and I believe is
to be a fantasy is what I also regard as
perhaps the worst essay ever written by
a major figure all those politics and
the English
language nothing is sillier then that is
and when all around idea not only is it
linguistically naive and philosophically
in an F but it's absolutely racist
through and through because what he says
is that language has been infected by
politics and especially in the sense
that we now have words that rather than
giving us a direct view of the things to
which they supposedly refer so their
view as politicians always do and he
cites Russia and Italy and of course
Germany as he was writing in 1946 as
instances of this disease and he fears
as this disease will now overcome the
English language so his advice again has
several thoughts one is all new year's
good anglo-saxon words and don't
especially use words borrowed from the
French and the Italians the English has
been saying this for about 800 years the
French in your town always stand for
that effeminate decadence which good
English persons must avoid and the
second thing he says is don't use words
think without words as long as you can
and then only bring in the words after
the thought has been fully formed which
then raises the question well how is the
thought fully formed and what is this
what is it thought about and he says
well think in pictures to which I would
respond pictures of what in other words
if you think in pictures you must have
an object in mind if you have an object
in mind it must in fact be distinguished
from other objects if it is
distinguished from other objects it is
distinguished from other objects in a
language so even if you start relying on
pictures you are still relying on
something like a system of language and
then I'll just close this by giving you
the the English again
an antidote to this perverse and silly
view and that is the third book of
Jonathan Swift's Gulliver's Travels and
if you remember in the third book dollar
for visits the country of Lagado
and then we've got over there is an
academy obviously based on the Royal
British Royal Academy and guess what
that Academy has a project to do away
with words as much as possible and so to
recover our good and efficient and true
relationship to the world but how do
they do this some of you will recall I'm
sure the Guardians want to eliminate
language and have a direct relationship
to things therefore when they go out
into the world they carry huge map sacks
filled with as many things as they
believe they might want to refer to sure
the conversation of many Swift says when
to to such people are walking and
watches speak they sit down on the side
of the highway and they open up their
packs and then they show each other
things now I'm willing to say that if
the game is show of things that work
what if the game is Show and Tell
because the moment you try to relate the
things you are showing in terms of the
usual the usual structural relationships
that language handles of cause and
effect continuity continuity dependence
independence priority etc the moment
you've done that you're back in the
world of language and in the
superimposition of language on the
reality to which you thought you could
finally reach get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog